Yeah. I don't want to sound too
much like the shelving this,
but when I come home and dinner's not
ready, I go through the roof. Okay.
Donald Trump's misogyny is obvious.
It's part of his brand.
It's one of the reasons why he's
so famous in the first place.
And I'd argue that nearly
everybody already knows it,
but while some perceived Trump's
sexism as horrifying or dangerous,
millions of others don't really
think it's that big of a deal.
It's the difference between seeing Trump
like this versus something more like
this. Fire her and don't ever make
me talk to a woman that old again.
And that rather stark difference in
perspective is I think at the heart of why
Trump's sexism didn't derail his bid
for the White House in the way that most
political pundits predicted that it would.
Now we'll return to our friend
Jack from 30 rock in a moment.
We have a chance to make
this country great again,
but first we have to talk about how
the next president of the United States
views women treat women with respect.
Uh,
I can't say that again.
All right, good. All right.
It's not an exaggeration to say that
Donald Trump sees women as pieces of meat
who primarily exist for male pleasure
or as trophies to elevate men's social
status. This mentality even
extends to his own daughter.
I've said that if Ivanka warm my daughter,
perhaps I'd be dating her.
He projects a casual disregard
for the idea of consent.
I'll go backstage before a
show and everyone's getting
dressed and ready and I'm
allowed to go in because I'm the
owner of the pageant and therefore I'm
inspecting it. Is everyone
okay? You know that they did.
They would know is everybody okay?
And you see these incredible looking women
and so I sort of get away with things
like that. She was one of the most
beautiful women I had ever seen.
It was incredible.
This is a man who incessantly links
the inherent worth of women to their
physical appearance and to little else.
All of a sudden she's gained,
I mean literally she went up from
about 118 to about 170 pounds.
It was incredible. Well, obviously
it's great outer beauty. I mean,
we could say politically correct that
to look, doesn't matter, but the look,
obviously it matters. Like you wouldn't
have your job if you weren't beautiful.
All of this is again,
obvious and uncontroversial.
So what's going on in our culture?
When a man can say things like this,
you know, I'm automatically attracted
to beautiful, I just start kissing them.
It's like a magnet. You just, I don't
even wait. And when you're a star,
they let you do it. You can do
anything. Grab 'em by the Pussy.
I can do any of that.
And then millions of Americans,
both men and women just shrug
it off and support him anyway.
Now I don't think the 60 million people
who voted for Donald Trump did so
because they agree with his sexist
behavior, at least not consciously.
Sure. Some certainly. But
the vast majority don't.
Most people are not Internet trolls.
During the 2016 election cycle,
we saw dozens of republican leaders
trying to distance themselves from Trump's
misogyny. Yet for most of them,
it still wasn't a deal breaker.
So we have to ask why.
Why wasn't such blatant and unashamed?
Misogyny a deal breaker.
The answer I'd argue has a lot to do
with the ways that our culture normalizes
sexism in the sociological sense.
Normalization is the process
by which a particular attitude,
ideology or behavior becomes established
and entrenched in social life.
It's the cultural process through which
we come to expect and accept something
as natural and as well normal.
The cultural process of normalization
is of course multifaceted.
It operates within many different
institutions simultaneously in families,
in schools, in workplaces, in churches,
in government and entertainment.
What does a gentleman,
but it's
that last one and your team that I want
to focus on here on the ways in which
mass media, friends, misogyny, and
sexism, because as bell hook says,
pop culture is where the pedagogy is.
It's where the learning is happening.
Donald Trump is a reality TV star.
He is first and foremost and entertain.
He revels in making a spectacle of
himself in a society that rewards him with
endless,
yeah,
media attention instead of hair.
I'll say it
well.
His outlandish behavior,
it's clear to me that Donald
Trump is always performing,
always putting on a show.
For an audience and his overt sexism is
an important part of that performance.
We get along very well and there's not
a lot of disagreement because ultimately
Ivana does exactly as I tell her.
I see. Wait a minute, right?
Right. Men, is that right?
Trump's right. Brand
of misogyny is so unapologetically over
the top that it feels very much like a
television caricature.
Maybe I could help her realize some other
life goal to become a doctor's nurse
or a lawyer.
It's mistress or even the president of
the United States shopping association.
I want you to get better because,
and I mean this,
I'm tired of talking this much tool,
a woman.
I'm not having sex with this
lovable misogynist archetype
is found everywhere in
pop culture. That's right. Barney
Stinson is back on the market.
Mothers lock up your daughters.
The only reason to wait a month
for sex is if the girl is 17 years,
11 months old.
You have been sexually harassing me.
He says the very first day of
class, sexually harassing. What
makes no sense to me. Why would I
harass somebody who turns me on?
There's the house.
I found America's top models
looked on the roof on ice and
Gisella sunbathing European style.
You can recognize people on Google Earth.
Of course not. I got a buddy of mine
at norad to have a spy drone fly over.
The thing about Jack Donaghy from 30
rock and the many other characters just
like him,
is that everybody knows they're sexist.
The characters know it,
the show knows it.
The audience knows across the board,
these characters engage in outlandishly,
sexist and sometimes downright massage
in his behaviors. What did I do?
You don't know. Oh, you poor dear.
Your ovaries are squirting so
much goofy juice into your brains.
You don't even know which way is up.
Something going with one of the girls
here and maybe it's that Russian dancer
with the tattoos,
which is the crazy sex drive fender
wide eyed farm girl would get off
the bus with big dreams of Broadway.
No idea what a casting director
could legally ask her to do,
hold or lick during an audition,
but at the end of the day,
there's still framed as lovable,
well-meaning guys, amazing guy.
He's fun.
One of my best friends
and he landed this hobby.
He's a good guy. By the end of each
episode, all has been forgiven again,
but no life lessons have really
been learned and it is on
these characters.
Sexism is never presented as serious
enough to permanently jeopardize their
friendships or their
relationships or their jobs.
In other words, no,
it's not a deal breaker.
This is one of the ways that our culture
works to normalize sexist behavior.
Not by denying that it's sexist,
but by acknowledging it and then
framing it as mostly harmless.
For the record, what do you guys are
doing is really creepy? You know what?
If it's creepy,
do use the internet,
military satellites and robot aircraft
to find a house full of gorgeous young
models so that I can drop in on them
unexpectedly, then fine. I'm creepy.
It's a younger man's game.
I can't say that I don't miss it.
You'd be in your office late at night.
The new girl would come in with
some flimsy excuse to be there. Oh,
Mr O'hare forgot to give you the factory.
We'll cook death rates and she laughed
at your lame joke touch on the arm.
Can you take your reward?
Now to be clear,
I don't believe the writers and producers
of this media or intending to help
normalize sexism. I think they
clearly intend to satirize it,
but when misogyny is consistently
framed as a lighthearted joke,
it's signals to viewers that sexism
isn't something all that serious.
I'd argue that this provides us with a
clue as to why Donald Trump's misogyny
isn't taken seriously either.
If we add a laugh track for
Trump's statements about women,
he becomes virtually indistinguishable
from another TV series. Calm carry.
I don't want to sound too
much like a chauvinist,
but when I come home and
dinner's not ready, I go through,
but in all honesty,
we don't need to add a laugh track because
Trump's audience provides one for him
ready and he referred to my hands.
If they're small,
something else must be spoiled.
I guarantee you there's no problem.
Okay.
Just like a TV show.
I think we have to face the hard
truth that for millions of people,
Donald Trump's sexism is not seen as
harmful because it's seen as just more
entertaining.
Trump excels at exploiting the media
landscape where misogyny is framed as just
guys being guys and it's something that
doesn't make those guys dangerous or
scary when Trump or his surrogates are
occasionally forced to respond to his
most egregious sexism.
They do it like this,
but this was locker room talk.
Notice that statements about locker room
talk or not a denial of sexism there,
an excuse for it.
They're an acknowledgement that yes,
Trump's statements may be sexist,
but it's mostly harmless.
It's just not that big of a deal,
but of course misogyny is that big
of a deal. Misogyny is dangerous,
especially to women on
both an interpersonal and
a public policy level and
Trump's presidency promises to bring
with it an attack on women's reproductive
rights and a dismantling of protections
against gender based discrimination.
Do you believe in punishment for abortion?
Yes or no.
Is a principal at the answer is that it
has to be some form of punishment for
the woman.
Yeah.
The important thing to understand
is that Trump and his brand of toxic
masculinity,
do you know how to exist in a vacuum?
He doesn't exist separate and apart
from the world that you and I inhabit,
his rise comes in part because we have
failed to challenge a culture that
tolerates sexist behaviors even
while acknowledging that they exist.
Donald J.
Trump be a misogynist,
but in a society that reduces sexism to
a joke he's widely seen as a level of.
So if you enjoyed that video,
please consider sharing it. Uh,
you can also go over to my patrion page
right here and help back the project.
Even just a few dollars a month
a really helps me out a lot. Um,
I will see you all in a few weeks
with another video critique.